um i saw you just had an incident with a
possum um what happened
what'd you say i had an instant you had
an incident with a pocket incident with
a possum yeah
they should have sat you next to me so
you can hear me
uh i did i was i was at the house
in oklahoma and i was just i was there
by myself
and i just grilled something on the
grill and i got it out i was letting it
cool off and i went back to get it and
it's a
damn possum over there look eating my i
actually grilled some fish oh
my god i was like hey man
i didn't actually see this whole thing i
didn't know what they ate
the food was in my mouth your food oh
i later got i i got to i don't know if i
have the video i ended up petting it and
hanging out with it
were you grilling a possum there it is
there i am petting it
i wasn't grilling a pot so look at it he
likes me real quick question have you
ever heard of rabies
yeah oh well you're probably not going
to air the next video well no
no i'm just kidding oh what oh what
anything left to eat he ate my food oh
my
god okay so john have you ever
encountered a wild animal well
the scariest time we were in
tanzania oh east africa
and a black mamba
oh which is a snake which i know which
is deadly
is deadly i did not see this black mamba
but everyone who was with me
saw it near me and i had didn't see it i
was
walking the other way but i was close
enough to it that it could have
bitten me but i escaped it and then
everyone was like john did you just see
that black mamba
and i completely missed it but that's
probably why you didn't get bit though
because you didn't freak out
yeah well i didn't notice it that's what
i'm saying you were so calm and so it
was right there though it could have
gotten me
damn yeah that is wild because i've been
on one of those safaris i think they
just carry a gun in case they don't
carry like you know something safe for
life to get bit by
like wow that's scary yes so i
i didn't know to be scared or not
because i didn't actually see it but
everyone around me was very scared for
me
oh my god i'd have freaked out have you
have you ever had anything crazy like
animals i have
yeah not as scary as that okay um
but i i got chased by a pack of coyotes
once
come on i swear to god a pack you jonas
boys every one of you tell crap like
that
wait what do you mean like a pack of
kite that's dangerous yeah so
i was just coming out of a movie theater
and uh
this is in los angeles this is um los
angeles and
i step outside and start walking by
myself walking home my friend's like
we'll give you a rise like i want to get
some
fresh air and so i'm walking and then i
see these eyes
in the dark and then i see about six
more sets of eyes
and they just wanted an audience and
they take off running after me
that's terrifying so i go full sprint
like this about
half a mile uh to my house jump the
fence and they're all out the fence and
they don't chase people normally they do
in a pack though they will
so it was quite frightening i i i should
mention that when i was getting the
fresh air i may have
you know a little bit given an aroma
yeah
are you saying coyotes are attracted to
the smell
you have like a bunch of beverly hills
chihuahuas chasing like it's a wild
rabbit
yeah no one else was with me i can't be
sure that is what happened
oh my god
you lost god you lost me at fresh air in
los angeles
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure